last month Activision announced that the
ps3 and xbox 360 versions of call of
duty black ops 3 would not be including
the game single-player campaign now
while a lot of SBS games are popular for
their multiplayer here are six which
have really awesome single-player
campaign
Call of Duty is both defined what the
shooter genre is today and defined the
controversy over annual installments
that said no installment is nailed at
single-player campaign quite as well as
call of duty 4 modern warfare
modern warfare was the first game in the
franchise to depart from the world war 2
setting as the name implies you could
now get your hands on modern weaponry
technology and vehicles in addition to
the series of signature shootouts Modern
Warfare's campaign included clever and
stressful stealth missions as well as
intense narrative scenarios like the
gut-wrenching experience of your player
character slowly dying after the
explosion of a nuclear bomb the tight
pacing and blockbuster success of Modern
Warfare set a standard that plenty of
other games of shamelessly imitated ever
since before we got our hands on it it
would have been hard to guess that
Wolfenstein the new order would have a
great campaign given that Wolfenstein 3d
was pretty bare-bones as far as story
goes but it did and it was great in the
game's ultimate history version of world
war ii the third reich has completely
taken over Europe after the protagonist
BJ blaskowitz has fallen into a coma he
gets out of it and naturally it's up to
him to shoot everything back to justice
the brash gunplay and limited health
regeneration gave the action a great
sense of urgency and the writing takes
its cheesiness in its stride is
surprisingly funny and explores
interesting themes related to the nature
of war and to the impact on those caught
up in it as far as I'm concerned little
girl ghosts will always be terrifying
clearly monolith productions thought
much the same thing when they created
first encounter assault recon or if you
prefer beer it may have a very silly
acronym for a name but fear has a truly
creepy atmosphere and a detailed horror
story to scare the crap out of you even
though you're playing a badass soldier
with lots of guns uncovering what's
causing those supernatural bumps in the
night in fear is exceptionally cool and
the campaign cleverly balances its jump
scares and sure
with narrative twists and turns you know
it has really great stories books Metro
2033 was based on a book and it has a
great single-player campaign
you play as Artyom in a post nuclear
apocalyptic Russia where everything has
gone to [ __ ]
Society has retreated underground and
are now living in the labyrinth Ian's
metro system metro 2033 succeeds in its
pacing and rich game world one moment
you're shooting frantically at
horrifying mutants lurking in the dark
and the next you're speaking with
survivors and finding out how life goes
on even after the worst happened it also
replicates that post-apocalyptic
survival tension by having your bullets
be your currency do you shoot your way
through a problem or sneak past it to
save for upgrades your first glimpse of
rapture from the relative security of a
bathysphere is one of the coolest
moments in gaming and bioshock's
campaign just keeps delivering after
that Bioshock is one of my favorite
games of all time and the story is
wonderful
you play as Jack who finds himself
uncovering the messy social and
political history of the formerly
utopian city of Rapture and dealing with
the result of its downfall jack has a
hell of a time dealing with the mutated
former citizens of rapture getting
injected with plasmids being
double-crossed dealing with batshit
crazy larger-than-life characters and
dealing with the consequences of his
choices I'm sure many of you would agree
that this list of excellent singleplayer
FPS campaigns would not be complete
without half-life 2 you probably don't
need me to reiterate what half-life is
done for the FPS genre and gaming in
general but I'll do my best to summarize
carp life two largely defined what it
was to integrate a nuanced
compelling narrative into shooter
exploring and interacting with the world
as a means of storytelling proves to be
a very effective way of drawing you into
the story as its unravels great gunplay
and puzzles aside half life to succeeds
by building a fascinating world filled
with characters you care about and an
exciting sci-fi plot to get swept up in
let me know down in that comment section
which singleplayer FPS campaign is your
favorite and be sure let me know if I
missed out on mentioning your pick I
will catch you again next week